cici's candidacy was top news in
Egyptian media it's long been an open
secret that the country's top officer
had higher political ambitions in Tahrir
Square the birthplace of the 2011
uprising people praised CC who they
believed was a key force in banning the
Muslim Brotherhood well I CC is an
honorable man and most Egyptians love
him he rescued Egypt from the terrorist
Brotherhood who were taking the Egyptian
people down the road to hell when he did
javea we got to a like that that we
wanted him to be a candidate because
there's no one else like him late
Wednesday CC went live on state
television to declare his candidacy
saying he was wearing his uniform for
the last time Lydia has go woody I
announced my intention to run for the
Egyptian presidency and I would be
honored by your support has a shuttle
phone Ozzy after three years of unrest
many Egyptians are looking for an
assertive leader to take power CC seems
to embody that wish but his many
opponents accuse him of orchestrating
last year's military coup that ousted
the freely elected president and Muslim
Brotherhood leader Mohamed Morsi they
fear Egypt is already sliding back into
dictatorship